[Музика]
Привіт усім і ласкаво просимо на
урок англійської, моє ім'я сьогодні невідоме,
ми продовжимо розмову про
стиль життя молоді, і це частина
2 нашого герундію
, це граматика, яку ми почали
вивчати минулого разу. Добре, давайте перейдемо до
завдання з самого початку, зараз
ми поглянемо на слова
та картинки, які насправді зображують
спосіб життя різних людей, звичайно,
підлітки також мають такий спосіб життя,
тож давайте подивимося на імена
цих стилів життя любителів спорту  трудоголік
диван картопля
книжковий черв'як homebody toka holic марнотратник
чи маєте ви уявлення про те, як ці слова
можна використовувати в реченнях і що
вони означають, перш ніж ми перейдемо до значень,
давайте подивимося на малюнки та
спробуємо уявити слова з
ілюстраціями, щоб  перша картинка, на якій ми
бачимо хлопчика, який лежить на ньому, і
робить щось, що ми насправді робимо не
так, тому він може бути лінивим, мало
робить, не робить багато речей на
дозвіллі  Як ти думаєш, як ми
могли б назвати таку людину так, як можна було б назвати
її словом чи навіть фразою, щоб
він лежав на дивані, і ми могли б назвати його
кушеткою, так що кушетка
означає ледачий, наступний  ми
бачимо чоловіка, який сидить на лавці і виконує
якусь роботу, тому він наполегливо працює, оскільки він
за ноутбуком виконує якусь роботу, і його,
ймовірно, працює понаднормово, чи не так,
як ми назвали б цю людину,
як це було б словом, що робити
ви називаєте це людиною, це трудоголік
людина, яка працює занадто багато, добре, наступне
фото тут ми бачимо дівчину
без макіяжу, це щось інше,
так що ви можете побачити кольори яскравих
кольорів на її обличчі, і, ймовірно, вона є
шанувальником спорту, вона  намагається підтримати свою
улюблену спортивну команду добре, як ви думаєте,
це всі зображення, які ви
збираєтеся поєднати зі словами ні, жодне слово не
залишилося ми переходимо до наступних
фотографій, добре, більше фотографій, щоб більше
слів відповідали давайте  подивіться на
першу, тому тут  ми бачимо, як дівчина
несе сумки, і, ймовірно, вона
правильно ходила по магазинах, тому якщо вона дуже любить
робити покупки і витрачає на це занадто багато
грошей, ми б назвали таку
людину марнотраткою, тому ця людина зазвичай
витрачає гроші на різні речі, добре,
що ми можемо  подивіться на наступному
зображенні, імовірно, людина, яка залишається
вдома, почувається дуже комфортно,
п’є чай або каву в кухлі, тому
є камін, і ця людина, ймовірно,
не дуже любить виходити на вулицю,
як ви називаєте цю людину,
це домашня людина  людина, яка любить
сидіти вдома інша фотографія, інша
картина, яку ми бачимо тут, це чоловік, який
читає книгу, і навколо нього так багато
книг, що він, напевно, у
книжковому магазині вибирає для нього щось нове
для читання, якщо людина так любить читати,
що може»  без нього ми б
назвали цю людину книжковим черв'яком, і останнє, з ким
ця людина розмовляє по телефону
, припустимо, що вона проводить занадто багато часу в
Інтернеті на своєму телефоні, цій людині
зателефонують у алкоголіку  o ця людина
занадто багато розмовляє по телефону і проводить
забагато часу в Інтернеті, використовуючи свій телефон,
добре зроблено,
зараз ми збираємось узгодити ці слова
з їхніми визначеннями, тому нам потрібно
зіставити слова та пояснення зі
словами спортивний фанат робота з taka holic
couch  картопля домашній трудоголік і
марнотратник, який ви могли побачити на
попередніх фотографіях, а тепер давайте подивимося
на визначення, тож перше
визначення, яке вони вважають за краще залишатися вдома, а не виходити на
вулицю, їх основним інтересом є
покупка одягу та модно одягатися
, вони люблять грати чи дивитися  спорт
D вони залежні від мобільних телефонів E
вони дуже працьовиті і часто
працюють понаднормово F вони вважають за краще дивитися телевізор
, ніж виходити або займатися спортом і G
вони люблять постійно читати, тому давайте
почнемо з першого слова зліва під
номером один  вболівальник спорту
, який любить спорт,
займається спортом, грає в нього або дивиться, тому
нам потрібно буде зіставити це слово з
визначенням C, вони люблять грати  займатися або
дивитися спорт номер два книжковий черв'як, тож
це щось пов'язане з
книгами, які ви пам'ятаєте, і це було
б правильно  D залежний від мобільних
телефонів номер чотири couch potato, яке
визначення ми відповідаємо цьому слову,
звичайно, F вони вважають за краще дивитися телевізор
, ніж виходити або займатися спортом, вони
наче ледачий люди, право номер п'ять,
домашні люди, ці люди вважають за краще залишатися
вдома, ніж виходити на вулицю  і це
число шість трудоголік, трудоголік
зазвичай працює так багато, і вони витрачають так
багато часу на роботу, що вони роблять це з часом
і так далі, так що це було б e вони
дуже працьовиті, і вони часто працюють
понаднормово наступне слово і останнє
тут  це марнотратник, тож кого ми можемо
назвати марнотратником, щоб це була людина,
яка зазвичай витрачає занадто багато грошей на
модне одягання та купівлю нового
одягу,
так само визначення B добре j  добре,
тепер ви знаєте ці слова, як вони
вживаються та що вони означають, тож тепер давайте
перейдемо до наступної частини, давайте перейдемо до
наступної вправи. Наше завдання —
завершити речення словами, які два слова
з рядка є непарними, тому візьміть  подивіться
на слова, і тепер ми збираємось зіставити
їх з реченнями відповідно до їх
контексту, щоб мати два слова, це означає,
що два слова не будуть використані в
реченнях, тут ми маємо п'ять речень,
але сім слів OJ odd Zywicki optimist
buddha dois zai box нижнє речення
номер один Моніка така минулого тижня, що
вона купила дві пари туфель і три
шовкові сукні, які були вдвічі ціни. Раджа
Моніка Німбус з'являється в новому куполі,
як і раніше дає дім Ану там зараз,
яке слово буде використано для  зателефонуйте Моніці,
це буде слово марнотратник, це
правильно, ми використовуємо слово марнотратник, щоб
говорити про людей, які витрачають занадто багато
грошей на одяг, добре, друге
, як хтось хлопець Меліси
носить багато сорочок з журналом команди  Ос ходить
на багато ігор і впадає в депресію, коли
його улюблена команда втрачає улюблені команди
логотипи футболки ігри що це про
це, безумовно, про спорт
О, хлопець Мелісси є фанатом спорту,
і як спортивний фанат, він робить це
добре номер три зараз, люба, будь ласка, не
нехай надворі так гарно, і все, що ти
хочеш робити, це дивитися футбол, щоб
людина хотіла залишатися вдома, хоче
дивитися футбол, і вона не хоче
кудись виходити, тож як би ми назвали
таку людину, як було б слово  використовуйте
в описі добре, ми можемо
використати фразу «диванна картопля», щоб описати
таку людину, щоб ця людина була лінивою і
не хоче нікуди виходити
. Чоловік Олени, мабуть, має бути а, тому що він
проводить своє життя, ходити в сусідні бібліотеки
та книжкові магазини  що ми можемо знайти в
бібліотеках що ми можемо знайти в книгарнях,
безумовно, книги та літературу, то
як ми назвати людину, яка не може жити
без книг
, це книжковий черв'як, добра робота і останнє
речення  тут
не просіть Маріано піти з нами,
і він скаже ні на кожне
запрошення, навіть якщо ви поїдете святкувати
його власний день народження 9 червня.
зателефонуйте йому так, яким
словом ви будете називати Маріано, щоб, якщо
він любить залишатися вдома, він не любить
вечірки, назве його домашнім, тож
домашнім буде людина, яка вважає за краще залишатися
вдома, ніж робити щось інше, ніж
виходити, наприклад, добре  молодець, тепер
ви бачите, що є два слова
трудоголік і говорити холік, які дивні,
ви можете писати власні
речення з цими словами, тому не
забувайте, що трудоголік означає людину, яка
багато працює, а алкоголік - це людина,
яка  залежний від свого телефону добре,
тепер ми знаємо це, давайте подивимося на
іншу вправу. Наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
завершити речення правильними
формами слів у дужках,
щоб виконати цю вправу, щоб виконати цю вправу, вам потрібно буде
згадати, якими ми були  навчання на
попередньому уроці, коли ми говорили
про герундій, тож ми говорили
про слова simking та disliking і ми
говорили про дієслова,
після яких слід ing, тому ось що нам
потрібно зробити, давайте поглянемо на
перше речення  як приклад then enjoys
read science fiction, тому після дієслова
enjoys нам потрібно використати слово із закінченням ing,
і це було б then
enjoys read science fiction, тому давайте
наслідуємо приклад і виконаємо цю вправу
разом
номер два Шеріл запропонувала подивитися фільм
після уроків  то яку форму слова,
яку форму дієслова to see well, ми
використовуємо в цьому реченні, ми
розкриємо дужки, поставлені в цьому слові, у формі герундію,
тому ми додамо ing Cheryl запропонувала
подивитися фільм після уроків номер
три I must work  в туристичній індустрії,
можливо, я зможу повернути свою стару роботу,
тому після дієслова mis ми також будемо використовувати
ing, ми повинні сказати, що я сумую за роботою в
туристичній індустрії, четверте
, ви не проти, допоможіть мені перекласти це
літера після дієслова mind, яку ми будемо використовувати
ing, так що ви не заперечуєте, щоб допомогти мені перекласти
цю літеру, п’яте речення, про яке ви ніколи
не згадували, живете в Японії, як
довго ви там живете,
тому після згадки ми маємо
слово live, тому  речення буде
звучати так, як
ви ніколи не згадували про життя в Японії
до числа шість, якщо він продовжує приходити на
роботу пізно, його збираються звільнити,
тому після Keep також використовуватиме ing, якщо він
продовжує приходити на роботу пізно,
його звільнять і  останній номер сім
Деббі закінчила навчання за кордоном минулого року
після дієслова finish ми будемо
використовувати ing of study, тому нам потрібно використовувати
закінчення слова study і
речення буде таким, як
Деббі закінчила навчання за кордоном минулого
року, добре, молодці  Тепер ви згадали
те, що ми дізналися на попередньому
уроці, тепер ви готові розглянути
їх трохи глибше, тому давайте повернемося до
граматичних пояснень про герундій, щоб,
як ви бачите зліва, герундій — це
дієслово plus ing стає відомим, і це
насправді те, що таке герундій, тому існує
три основних способи використання форми герундію,
які ми збираємося обговорити сьогодні,
тож перше як іменник або підмет
сервомотор Махабхарата як Аманда Я
трохи божевільний Вірджинія  давайте подивимося
на приклади шахрайство дуже поширене
в сьогоднішній школі читання – це діяльність,
яку слід пропагувати серед
підлітків, тому ми маємо ці слова читання
і обман із закінченням ing, і вони
стоять на початку речення,
вони є суб’єктами  речення номер
два ми використовуємо ing після прийменника, як
тут,
я втомився чекати на вас, він дуже
добре танцює, тому після прийменника
з у нас є слово waiting з ing
після прийменника at ми танцювали з
ing і це танцює
добре і що  про вирази
давайте подивимося на них немає сенсу робити
в чомусь не годиться робити
щось варте чи не варто
робити щось немає сенсу робити
щось не можна  допомогти робити щось
мати проблеми робити щось і мати
труднощі робити щось
замість слова робити ви можете використовувати будь-яку
форму герундій плавати бігати слухати дивитися
і так далі, і ось приклад
, немає сенсу сперечатися, давайте просто зупинимо
перепис майя, де вони сказали, що  virus
Tanima, тому після фрази немає
сенсу, ми маємо дієслово argue, тому
немає сенсу сперечатися добре, тому це
крихітне пояснення коротке, але корисне, тепер
давайте попрактикуємося, наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб поставити
дієслово у правильну форму, давайте
подивимося  у першому реченні мій брат
добре пірнає, тому тут ми маємо фразу
з прийменником бути хорошим у чомусь,
якщо у нас є прийменник at, нам потрібно
використати дієслово dive, тому ми повинні
сказати, що мій брат добре пірнає, добре
добре, давайте перейдемо до номеру два, вона
боїться втратити свого хлопця, щоб
чогось боятися або боятися
щось зробити,
тому нам також потрібен прийменник, тому
вона боїться мене  Зверніть увагу на її хлопця,
зверніть увагу, що буква e вилучена
зі слова, тому вона змінена за допомогою ing l
OS ing номер три нам було важко
знайти шлях до музею геномний або
Нобель не є замком Museo latosha
puedes mozo нам потрібно використати  після
деяких фраз мати труднощі зробити
щось
є одним із них, тому ми повинні сказати, що нам було
важко знайти дорогу до музею,
молодець
номер чотири розуміти узи
родини в п’єсах Шекспіра
важливо для розуміння його мистецтва
в цілому
О, JA resuming vs kisame Xperia P essa була люта Летиція,
припустимо, що це сріблястий
костюм, гарна гірчиця, все ще тепла, тому тут ми
маємо слово зрозуміти, яке є дієсловом
для розуміння на початку
речення, воно стає підметом, і
ми повинні використовувати  Форма цього
світу, тому ми скажемо, що розуміння
родинних уз у п’єсах
Шекспіра важливо наступне число п’ять
немає сенсу купувати стару машину
немає сенсу після цієї фрази ми  потрібно
використовувати ing, тому я скажу, що
немає сенсу купувати стару машину шоста, яку
моя сестра хоче стати поп-зіркою
зірка, але
тут у нас є слово фантазія, за яким
слідує ing, тому ми маємо сказати, що
моя сестра огорожує стати поп-зіркою,
гарна робота номер сім, ми закінчили
писати наші есе до полудня після того, як
слова закінчаться, оскільки ви вже знаєте, що нам
потрібно  використовуйте форму слова ing,
тому ми скажемо так, що ми закінчили
писати наші есе до обіду, добре,
а останнє число вісім
я ненавиджу робити покупки в суботу після
дієслів симпатії в цьому вподобанні, таких як
люблю, як ненавиджу, не люблю і  так далі і так
далі нам потрібно використовувати ing тут, ми
також будемо використовувати його, звичайно, я ненавиджу робити
покупки в суботу
добре добре зроблено, давайте перейдемо
до наступної частини, тепер давайте подивимося
на форми герундію, які використовуються в
пісні відомих співаків ти  можливо, ви вже
багато чули ці слова у своєму житті,
і ви можете мати певний досвід,
який ви будете використовувати у своїх вправах, які
ви виконуєте на герундій і так далі,
і насправді найважливіше,
що ви помічаєте ці структури і
знаєте, як  використовуйте їх у повсякденному
мовленні,
коли ви знаходите їх у книгах, коли ви
чуєте їх у піснях, коли чуєте
їх у фільмах чи серіалах,
дуже добре, якщо ви можете їх розпізнати, тому
тепер давайте подивимося на приклади
на дошці  вони показують нам рядки
з текстів деяких пісень, тому
перша пісня Marin five, вона буде кохана, я
не проти проводити кожен день на
твоєму кутку під проливним дощем, тому я
не проти робити те, чого я не роблю  розум
витрачати кожен день наступний Бруно
Марс лінива пісня перший рядок
говорить, що сьогодні я не хочу нічого робити,
я просто хочу лежати в своєму ліжку,
що ти підеш, Бруно Марс, до речі,
канапе, так  Мені
нічого не хочеться робити  ing означає, що я
нічого не хочу робити, але після того, як я
не відчуваю, що ми використовуємо
слово зроби добре, третій Біллі
Айліш, ти повинен побачити мене у короні, скажи
мені, що гірше жити чи вмирати
вперше  слова lemon або dying
використовуються як іменники і як суб'єкти
і четвертий один двадцять один пілот не може
не закохатися, так, до речі, ви
могли почути цю пісню вперше у виконанні
Елвіса Преслі, але, можливо, двадцять один
пілот вам більше знайомий  тож давайте
подивимося на тексти пісень візьми мене за руку
візьми також усе моє життя, тому що я не можу
не закохатися в тебе, тому
безкоштовно
не можу не робити щось не можу допомогти,
супроводжується ing це означає, що я можу зр
бити  все, що я закохаюся в тебе,
і я нічого не можу з цим зробити,
так що це приклади
з пісень, а тепер давайте перейдемо до вашого домашнього
завдання, ваша домашня робота досить проста,
вам потрібно послухати одну з цих пісень
про які ми згадували раніше і
зверніть увагу на слова w  Закінчення
та як вони використовуються,
ви також повинні прочитати текст пісні під час
прослуховування, щоб ви могли шукати в Google
текст пісні та читати їх, коли
слухаєте пісню, ви можете вибрати одну
або ви можете прослухати всі з них, я сподіваюся, що
ви"  Буду насолоджуватися цим, це все на
сьогодні, дуже дякую за
увагу, побачимось наступного разу
[Музика]